les grandes sociétés technologiques
albanese des marchés depuis l'hiver
dernier avec le travail à distance les
ventes en ligne la visioconférence
regardez ce graphique c'est l'évolution
du poids des secteurs de réuni voyez
depuis les années 2000 les petits points
là c'est la santé les services
financiers la consommation l'industrie
et sert à la valeur le poids dans
l'indicé s&p 500 est demeuré à peu près
stable alors que la valeur des
technologies a bondi c'est à peu près
40% du s&p 500 et ça ressemble à ce
qu'on connaissait au tournant des années
2000 quand on a connu la grande crise
la grande bulle technologique on va
parler avec simon plante qui est
gestionnaire de portefeuille et premier
vice-président la banque nationale à la
financière banque nationale
bonsoir bonsoir est-ce qu'on revient est
ce qu'on a vécu en 2000 - ben ça ça ne
plus aller à 1999 c'est vrai c'est ce
qu'ils aiment tant jambes de sociétés
technologiques qui prend de plus en plus
de place puisque ça va être présent
c'est beaucoup plus démocratique
accessible mais on commence à voir des
exagérations dents dans certaines
évaluations et quand on regarde le
nasdaq qu'on va le voir dans le
graphique là on a eu en 2020 la chute
qu'on a connus du 20 février au 20 mars
à peu près là et la remontée du nasdaq
après et 28 % d'augmentation donc en
2020 c'est quoi les ressemblances que
vous voyez avec de mine mais si c'est
dans le fond là de plus en plus
l'histoire sociétés sont très
accrocheuse que je peux donner quelques
exemples ça fait que yann un peu aidé
entre l'histoire le potentiel récit
qu'on fait d'une entreprise qui les
fondamentaux financiers ça décroche
je veux donner quelques exemples puis on
va vous donner un exemple 1999 on peut
penser amazon quelqu'un qui avait décidé
d'investir un raisonnement 1999 il y
avait raison sur le plan d'affaires le
commerce en ligne allait prendre de plus
en plus de place jeff bezos c'était un
gestionnaire capable
la seule chose c'est que cette personne
n'était pas la seule à y penser puis le
titre était vraiment prêt mis au point
que quand l'éthiopien chuté lors de la
bulle technologique
le tuteur monter leurs progrès signer
c'est dit
à plus tard qu'on avait retrouvé notre
note un autre conteur donc ont arrêté
dix ans sans faire de vendre puis un peu
certaines histoires certains récits
qu'on peut voir actuellement bon test là
par exemple que cela vous en parliez je
pense c'est une société qui qu'un
produit qui va être présents même
événement se dit qu'un jour il ya deux
visions produire autant de véhicules que
toyota on parle de 10 millions de
véhicules n'ont produit actuellement
c'est environ 500000 c'est l'objectif
permanent ce qui est mentionné dans un
tweet ou courant de l'année qui pense à
son avis que son titre est surévalué
pour lui l'illustré je donne un exemple
mais d'ici cinquante est cela qu un
objectif ambitieux c'est faire environ
100 milliards de ventes
disons qu'ils font qui font des profits
d'environ 15 milliards 1 30 foulée
profile un second qui est quand même
relativement raisonnable pour une
société de croissance l'entreprise
devrait vendre environ 400 450 milliards
c'est l'évaluation qu'elle est déjà en
bourse
actuellement donc dans le fond marché
est en train d'évaluer le potentiel des
cinq prochaines années déjà dans son
prix d'action puis puis la preuve que
calme depuis son équipe de direction
pense le titre et peut-être surévalué
ils ont émis récemment cinq milliards
d'actions donc d'enfoncer comme une
devise pour les monétiser compte
d'argent pour renflouer leurs coffres
donc c'est un signe que même la société
est les dirigeants la société pense
qu'il peut être surévaluée zoom c'est
l'entreprise qui pourrait faire les
réunions à plusieurs connaisseurs exact
je vous donne un exemple avec zoom c'est
bien une progression son chiffre
d'affaires évidemment tout le monde se
connecte pour de la vidéoconférence
croissance de 300% martyrs de référence
en moyenne sur le s p 500 qui sont les
500 plus grandes entreprises transige à
new york
les sociétés se transigent environ 2 à 3
fois les ventes mais mme actuellement se
transige à 50 fois les ventes
donc il ya vraiment plusieurs
investisseurs qui se réfugient dans
cette histoire qui ont pu s'imaginer
dans un monde où on est vaccin qui
commencerait distribuer ce soir autant
d'adoption selon entente croissance du
nombre d'abonnés
ouais ben c'est plus qu'un convoi de bex
et par automne une société américaine
d'équipement d'exercice ouais
selon des données il ya plus de gens qui
s'entraîne aujourd'hui à la maison
depuis le creux vide plus de monde font
de l'activité mais combien dure si
j'avais pu s'entraîner dans les jeans
dans les salles entraînement des
immigrés vers des salles d'entraînement
dans leur résidence ce qui est un gros
transfert de richesse qui passe de salle
d'entraînement au niveau de
l'entraînement personnel mais
aujourd'hui si on regarde pour
l'attendre encore une excellente société
comme jeudi et un beau potentiel
la seule chose c'est aujourd'hui cette
société russe transitant vers 1 35
milliard de dollars américains donc
c'est comme payer environ 2000 dollars
l'usagé est usager loupé à peu près un
abonnement d'environ 10 à 20 dollars
américains par mois donc imaginer le
temps que ça peut prendre pour
rentabiliser
donc ces sociétés là ils peuvent livrer
la marchandise une fois par an qui est
vraiment une croissance des prochaines
années
l'exécutif d'une manière impeccable
absolument pour que plus pour un progrès
si vous êtes passionnés merci mon plant
merci ça fait plaisir
non